hello and welcome to this video on
playing vbar and I'm upon up probably
not for long
it mmediately but it's the triumph of
the queen's gambit accepted that you win
a pawn and move to I came oh why is he
going to eat you it's uncommon
yeah just normal development tonight is
normally on f3 in such a position not
quite certain if there is a big point to
having it only tool the pin is I was
still rather annoying
I came probably just develop how do we
unpin this maybe we should be 7m some
not what you originally dream of but
maybe queen bee three is even playable
yeah hmm not happy here okay I
definitely need to trade stuff
now that was a good development for me
trading that many pieces is definitely
helpful white is still okay he's got
yeah this move Knight f5 it's it's very
active so he shouldn't be in any
substantial danger of being worse but
you need to stay active that's important
sometimes white players some kind of get
into this kind of this passive mindset
somehow and then you can get problems
with the IQ p.m. okay it's not super
simple for him to play this I also had
8th why is that possible
it looks like a wrong setup couldn't
deal with the Queen to 297
my idea now is rookie one check and
Queenie form
hmm yeah rook takes probably
okay now let's first use the King and
then stopping Knight c4 and now d3
should win the pawn can almost pre move
it the knight is pinned so no trickery
you know okay now what could have taken
already of course of any component name
but there's no real way out down for
white
[Music]
don't want to allow 97 you cannot defend
g3u and before that's not working
okay
ma'am that the opening went went wrong
for me somehow ninety-two looks a bit
odd I'm sorry I was entirely wrong
button looks a bit odd but I mean okay
it's still active so white is not going
to be worse yeah I mean this this should
be kind of okay but from here I should
probably think about possible
improvements the engine is just
completely unfazed by everything res gt5
I would never consider that with this
kind of thing going on engine says equal
ok so this is a little bit retro but but
maybe it's not so terrible it is it is
an issue for water this is not so active
really
so my slowish buildup is maybe not so
possible text to exploit it and a very
decisive why would you 190 form and now
the trade said I mean the engine says
I'm ok maybe I am I have 96 if he does
not take himself now I have 96 and here
ok this is this is not so good this is
bad I am preventing Bishop to g5
it's probably roughly equal slide edge
for white maybe and here yeah I'm okay
yeah I've got the blockade and decent
enough control this is a bit odd and
this blindness is the game away you
should just stay here with the normal
move let's say Queen d2 and even if we
trade everything I'm even here this is
still not terrible King f1 or something
I'm a little bit better of course when
his bonus is not great on the form so
it's not something you should lose after
this I'm just exchanged up for for
nothing and I don't think I made a big
mistake after that was a fairly fairly
clean conversion Oh
somehow the webcam is frozen that's
funny don't know for how long
okay guys thanks for watching